ce soir on va donc très largement
s'arrêter sur cette double attaque
meurtrière survenue hier en norvège le
bilan est d'au moins 92 morts
comment expliquer un tel drame qui se
cache derrière cette tuerie beaucoup de
questions mais d'abord les faits la
norvège frappé donc en son coeur une
explosion en plein centre d'oslo suivie
d'une fusillade sur une île plus au sud
un homme
cet homme a tué de sang froid 85
personnes
il a été arrêté et inculpé les faits et
le récit signé hakim abdel khaleq sur
les rivages de l'île des corps inanimés
sans doute abattu quelques instants plus
tôt par le tireur peut-être cet homme
filmé par la caméra d'un hélicoptère
pendant près d'une heure trente
le tireur a traqué et achever ses cibles
des dizaines d'adolescents de 14 à 18
ans abattu froidement et secouriste
ramène un par un les victimes et les
rescapés des jeunes ensanglanté certains
corps sont sans vie il est 17 heures
hier soir l'île d'utoya bascule dans
l'horreur
beaucoup se jette à l'eau pour tenter
d'échapper à la fusillade qui fera au
moins 85 morts
pour fuir le carnage certain âge au
large des centaines de mètres eux sont
encore vivants
d'autres se cachent derrière les rochers
ici à gauche de l'image une silhouette
elle tend le bras pour attirer les
secours sur le bord de la route
des dizaines de rescapés les 85 victimes
participaient à un rassemblement de
jeunes du parti travailliste
elles sont tombées sous les balles d'un
homme qui se présentait comme policier
ils étaient habillés en policiers et
tenté d'agir comme s'il était là pour
nous aider
selon les témoins le suspect a tiré de
manière froide et méthodique après avoir
attiré les jeunes dans un local
j'ai entendu un tir passer juste à côté
de ma tête je l'entends encore détonné à
l'intérieur je suis tombé et j'ai rampé
jusqu'au rocher on s'est caché dans
l'eau à quelques mètres de nous on a vu
une fille allongée en sous vêtements
elle était mort à 19 heures 120 minutes
après le début de la fusillade
les commandos de la police norvégienne
débarque le tireur est enfin neutraliser
il est également suspecté d'être à
l'origine de l'attentât survenu quelques
heures plus tôt à 30 km de là en plein
coeur d'oslo au pied des immeubles qui
abrite le premier ministre et le
ministère des finances
il est 15 heures 25
quand une voiture piégée explose cette
mort une dizaine de blessés graves sur
des centaines de mètres les vitres sont
soufflées les débris jonchent le sol à
l'eau et aux éau est ce que quelqu'un a
besoin d'elle
avec 92 morts la norvège vie ce soir la
page la plus sombre de son histoire
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
bonsoir stéphanie perez on vous retrouve
en direct doute hoya l'île où s'est
déroulée cette tuerie qui a donc coûté
la vie à 85 personnes
un terrible bilan qui pourrait encore
s'alourdir et qui s'explique en partie
par la configuration des lieux
oui on vous l'avait dit 85 victimes au
moins sur cette île d'utoya qui se
trouve au milieu du lac derrière moi
cette petite île eh bien on ne la voit
pas depuis le rivage où je me trouve
elle est très isolé et c'est ce qui
explique pourquoi le tireur a pu agir
seul pendant près de deux heures
en fait les jeunes victimes ont été
prises au piège parce qu'il y a très peu
de maisons aux alentours pendant très
longtemps quand elles ont crié à l'aide
des biens à leurs cris ont résonné dans
le vide
quand enfin elles ont pu être entendus
et bien les quelques riverains qui ont
essayé de venir les secourir en bateau
ou à leur tour été pris pour cible tout
était donc réuni pour créer un huis clos
tragique pour que cette petite île selon
les propres termes du premier ministre
norvégien pour que cette petite île se
transforme en enfer
et ce soir justement on en sait plus sur
le profil de l'auteur présumé de ces
attaques il a été interpellé et
incarcéré
il s'agit d'un homme un homme âgé de 32
ans qui serait selon les enquêteurs
proche des milieux d'extrême droite un
amateur de chasse et de jeux vidéo
portraits signés amira soualem anne
heche behring breivik 32 ans
le responsable présumé des deux attaques
d'hier en norvège
décrit par les témoins comme un tueur
froid et méthodique
il tirait sur tout le monde sans
réfléchir je pense qu'il avait des
problèmes
quelques heures après la fusillade la
police perquisitionne son domicile et
fouillent la ferme qui lui appartient
une activité qui lui aurait permis
d'acheter six tonnes d'engrais en mai
dernier des engrais qui peuvent entrer
dans la fabrication d'une bombe
mais qui est vraiment à neige behring
breivik un sympathisant d'extrême droite
qui postent régulièrement des
commentaires sur ce forum et s'érige
contre le nombre grandissant de
musulmans en europe
pouvez-vous me mentionné un seul pays
dans lequel le
le ti culturalisme a été une réussite
quand il englobe l'islam à neige behring
breivik a d'ailleurs été membre du frp
un parti d'extrême droite norvégien
parti qu'il a quittée en 2006 pour des
raisons encore inconnues et blair on m'a
appris tout à l'heure que cet homme a
fait partie de la section jeunes de
notre parti et qu'il a mis fin à son
adhésion il ya déjà quelques années on
ne sait pas grand chose de lui il n'a
pas spécialement attiré l'attention
quand il était dans nos rangs quelques
jours avant la tuerie le suspect posté
ce message sur son profil twitter une
personne avec une croyance a autant de
force que 100 mille personnes qui n'ont
que des intérêts une citation qui sonne
aujourd'hui comme un énigmatique
avertissement au moins 93 morts et près
de 100 blessés c'est donc le tout
dernier bilan de la double attaque
survenue vendredi en norvège le pays est
en deuil et l'émotion immense images
fortes de cette journée la cérémonie qui
s'est tenue ce matin en la cathédrale
d'oslo alors qu'à l'extérieur vous le
voyez des centaines d'anonymes ont
déposé des gerbes de fleurs on va y
revenir très largement dans un instant
mais d'abord on va s'intéresser à
l'auteur présumé de cette tuerie qui
juste avant le massacre a posté sur
internet un journal et une vidéo récit
hakim abdel khaleq froid méthodique
calculateur anders behring breivik avait
soigneusement préparé ces attaques
depuis octobre 2009
dans une vidéo qu'il a postée lui même
sur internet peu avant l'attentât
il se définit comme un chevalier parti
en croisade prête à se battre contre
l'islam qu'il présente comme un cheval
de troie qui selon lui menacerait
l'europe
il y fustige également ce qu'il appelle
le marxisme culturel et considère que le
terrorisme est un moyen d'éveiller les
masses
la vidéo est accompagnée d'un manifeste
titré 2083 une déclaration européenne
d'indépendance 1500 pages qu'il a
rédigée pendant neuf ans où il affiche
notamment sa haine de la gauche
travailliste qui pour lui affaibli
l'identité norvégienne une sorte de
testament politique parfois incohérents
à la page 1436 il écrit je serai perçu
comme le plus grand monstre nazi jamais
connu depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
l'homme arrêté pour le meurtre d'au
moins 93 personnes reconnaît les faits
explique son avocat sur la télévision
norvégienne
un an plus tard ce qu'il a dit c'est
qu'il voulait un changement de la
société et de son point de vue cela doit
se passer à travers une révolution il
pense que ce qu'il a fait n'est pas
quelque chose qui devrait être puni
sofade interrogé par les enquêteurs il
affirme avoir agi de manière isolée dit
qu'il était seul mais la police doit
vérifier tout ce qu'il raconte
certaines déclarations de témoins
rendant incertaine la question de savoir
s'il y avait un ou plusieurs tireurs
le tueur présumé ici en combinaison anti
armes chimiques comparaîtra demain
devant un juge
il pourrait s'exprimer plus longuement
sur les motifs précis de son geste
bonsoir fait les prochains on vous
retrouve en direct d'utoya l'île sur
laquelle s'est donc déroulée cette
tuerie non loin d'oslo
une certitude ce soir philippe le tueur
avait tout planifié depuis longtemps
oui c'est vrai dans ce mémoire de 1500
pages il se terminait trois heures
exactement avant l'attentât où il disait
le terrorisme est utile pour réveiller
les masses donc aujourd'hui les
policiers essayent de savoir si oui ou
non il y avait des complicités donc
beaucoup de gens ont été interrogés la
police a même fait une opération dans
l'est d'oslo
mais pour l'instant elle se range à peu
à l'idée du tueur puisqu'il a reconnu
les fait il était seul pour agir il
était seul pour tuer ces 90 personnes
dans cette île derrière moi le drame
pour toute la norvège
oui la norvège qui pleure ses morts en
fin de matinée une cérémonie s'est tenue
en la cathédrale d'oslo en présence du
premier ministre et de la famille royale
alors qu'à l'extérieur des centaines
d'anonymes se sont retrouvés pour se
recueillir
récit en images avec fanny stellaire
même le roi et la reine de norvège n'ont
pu retenir leurs larmes
une cérémonie lourde en émotions où les
s'ouvrait le gouvernement comme des
milliers d'anonymes ont rendu un vibrant
hommage aux victimes de la tuerie
c'est d'une voix étranglée que le
premier ministre a pris la parole
chaque mort est une tragédie et trois
gardiens ce sens mais ensemble ils
représentent une tragédie nationale
dans l'assemblée
le chagrin marque les visages à
l'extérieur de la cathédrale un parterre
de fleurs
depuis hier des milliers de personnes
déposent des bouquets des bougies pour
s'associer au deuil que traversent les
familles des victimes
c'est un geste de soutien à ceux qui ont
perdu les leurs
tu peux le soir une dépose des fleurs et
on montre notre respect aux personnes
décédées dans ce petit pays d'à peine
cinq millions d'habitants
nombreux sont ceux qui connaissaient des
victimes de la tuerie
notre amie a disparu mais on espère
tellement la revoir ce qui est difficile
à vivre c'est que personne ne sait ce
qui lui est arrivé un pays en deuil mais
un pays sous surveillance aussi depuis
48 heures les militaires sont déployés
dans la ville
une situation que le pays n'a pas connu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale et
philippe c'est vrai que ce soir 48
heures après la la tragédie et l'émotion
est toujours immenses et les norvégiens
ont encore du mal à comprendre le drame
qui vient de se jouer
oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment la
première fois depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale qu'on assiste à un attentat
pareille à une fusillade pareil à un
crime pareil et donc les norvégiens sont
encore bouleversés mais ils font preuve
d'une attitude très très calme il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas de manifestations
réclamant plus de sécurité ou s'étonnant
que les forces de sécurité sont
intervenues très tard donc les
norvégiens reste vraiment très digne
dans leur deuil aujourd'hui et j'ai pu
observer cet après midi avec les
familles d'ailleurs des gens qui
attendent des nouvelles de leurs
disparus que c'était vraiment la dignité
qui régnait ici en norvège
oui les recherches poursuivent toujours
pour tenter de retrouver deux possibles
un nouvelle victime un périmètre de
sécurité a d'ailleurs été mise en place
la police tente ainsi de reconstituer le
parcours du tueur sur place philippe
rochot on va voir votre reportage tourné
cet après midi avec mathias barrois
l'île d'utoeya est devenue un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les familles et les amis
des étudiants tombés sous les balles du
tueur
plus de 90 d'entre eux sont morts ici
c'est triste c'est vraiment triste dans
les eaux profondes il resterait cinq
disparus les secours ont engagé à
présent ce petit sous-marin pour
rechercher les corps il y à aussi
incertitude sur le sort de quatre
personnes c'est pas facile pour tout le
monde mais on doit le faire pour les
mères les pères ils veulent savoir et
nous leur devons les vacanciers du
camping en face de l'île ont été les
témoins directs de cette tuerie et
souvent ils ont porté secours
j'ai tourné avec mon bateau et j'ai pu
sauver six personnes ma fiancée lui en a
sauvé 20 ou 30 avec le sien
le tueur avait fini de tirer la police
s'occuper de lui mais s'il restait
encore beaucoup de gens a sauvé ce soir
les vacanciers du camping répondait aux
questions de la police
les enquêteurs veulent savoir comment
chaque victime du tueur est décédé mais
aussi pourquoi les secours ont mis deux
heures pour intervenir
j'étais chez moi et j'écoutais la radio
et j'ai entendu qu'il se passait quelque
chose
quand j'ai ouvert la fenêtre j'ai
entendu les fusillades mais je ne
pensais pas que c'était aussi grave à
l'hôtel qui fait face à l'île d'utoya
les familles des disparus ont attendu
des nouvelles toute la journée dans un
calme exemplaire
leur espoir reste entre les mains des
quelques 200 secouristes engagées pour
retrouver les disparus
et c'est donc sur cette petite île
située à une trentaine de kilomètres à
peine au nord ouest d'oslo que s'est
déroulé un effroyable huit clos de 95
minutes plus d'une heure et demie
pendant laquelle l'homme a froidement
abattu 85 personnes pour mieux
comprendre cette interminable calvaire
voici le témoignage de deux jeunes
rescapés
adrian 21 ans et éric 18 ans propos
rassemblés par amira souilem h1n1 comme
il est entré dans l'accord il nous a
demandé de nous regrouper autour de lui
et il a commencé à tirer a cédé foule il
nous suivait dans nos tentes à tirer
dans les tentes
je ne me rendais pas compte de ce qui
était en train de se passer c'est juste
qu'est ce que je vois une fille en
pleurs elle venait de le voir à battre
une autre personne
c'est alors que j'ai compris que ce
n'était pas un jeu c'était bien réel
des personnes ont commencé à tomber
devant moi à mes pieds je me suis alors
caché entre les corps quand le tireur
s'est approché j'ai fait semblant d'être
mort il était glaçant ils avançaient et
tuer les gens comme si de rien n'était à
un moment j'ai entendu c'est pas tout
près de moi il était au niveau de mon
visage j'entendais sa respiration
il était calme pas du tout pressé il
tirait lentement j'ai alors senti une
piqûre au niveau de mon épaule je
pensais qu'une pierre mauvais atteints
en fait c'était une balle ils venaient
de tirer sur moi j'ai vu un tas de
personnes mortes
le tireur s'approcher de plus en plus de
là où j'étais
alors je me suis jeté à l'eau j'ai nagé
tellement nager que j'ai eu des crampes
aux jambes j'étais sur le point de me
noyer
quand j'ai été secourus par des
riverains ce ne sont pas mes blessures
qui me font mal aujourd'hui j'ai vu des
amis mourir devant mes yeux c'est
affreux c'est ça qui est difficile à
accepter aujourd'hui
bonsoir stéphanie perez on vous retrouve
en direct d'oslo c'est vrai que ce soir
on a du mal à comprendre pourquoi la
police a mis si longtemps à intervenir
est arrivé sur place
oui ce sont clairement les questions que
les norvégiens se poser posent à leur
autorité
alors cet après midi les responsables de
la police ont essayé de répondre pour
pour donner quelques précisions
une première réponse très simple au
moment de la fusillade sur l'île d'utoya
et bien toutes les forces de police
étaient à oslo concentrer sur la
première attaque à ce moment là elle ne
savait pas exactement ce qu'il se
passait il était clair que le premier
ministre était visé la priorité c'était
donc les bâtiments du premier ministre
ensuite quand on a pris conscience quand
ils ont pris conscience de l'ampleur de
la crise sur eux sur l'île d'utoya eh
bien il a fallu du temps pour rassembler
unité d'élite et ça aussi ça demande un
certain temps surtout qu'à ce moment là
il était encore difficile d'évaluer la
gravité de la situation
l'autre difficulté c'est que cette île
on l'a dit est à une quarantaine de
kilomètres d'oslo il a donc fallu se
rendre sur place c'est une île il a
fallu trouver les bateaux il s'est passé
quelque chose de très très bête
le premier bateau qu'on utilisait les
les secours eh bien il a failli couler
parce qu'il y avait trop d'hommes à bord
est trop de matériel
tout cela explique pourquoi pourquoi le
tueur a pu agir seul pendant près d'une
heure et demie la nouvelle fait
sensation en norvège behring breivik
l'auteur des attaques terroristes qui
ont fait 77 morts l'été dernier est donc
déclaré pénalement irresponsable il
devrait ainsi échapper à la prison
l'avis a été rendu par les médecins
experts et repris par le parquet
philippe rochot cet homme au pull rouge
a tué 77 personnes
il a même reconnu les fait et pourtant
il n'ira pas en prison
andrei breivik l'auteur de l'attentât
d'oslo et de la fusillade de l'île
d'utoya a été reconnu comme non
responsable de ses actes il devrait être
interné en hôpital psychiatrique
des experts ont conclu que breivik avait
développé pendant longtemps des troubles
mentaux de la paranoïa qu'ils ont changé
on fait de lui ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
cinq mois après la norvège n'a pas
oublié la voiture piégée est conduite
par ce militant d'extrême droite en
plein coeur d'oslo
l'explosion qui frappe les bureaux du
premier ministre et fait déjà huit morts
et puis l'autre cauchemar sur l'île
d'utoya en plein rassemblement de la
jeunesse travailliste
breivik abattent froidement 69 personnes
pour manifester sa haine de la politique
d'immigration conduite par les
travaillistes
pour les survivants qui se trouvaient
sur l'île la seule pensée que breivik
n'ira pas en prison est insupportable
pendant tout le temps de la fusillade
j'étais certaine que ce n'était pas un
malade mental que c'était son image de
la société qui était complètement fausse
mais qu'il était sain d'esprit les
tribunaux peuvent encore mettre en doute
les rapports des deux psychiatres mais
la norvège se prépare à voir le
meurtrier de 77 personnes échapper à la
prison
c'est d'abord donc ce rebondissement à
quelques jours du procès du tueur de
masse anders breivik en norvège
après une première expertise qui le
déclare est irresponsable
un nouveau collège de psychiatres a
rendu des conclusions inverses
il est reconnu sain d'esprit et donc
pénalement responsable loïc de la
mornais lorsqu'on dirt breivik esquisse
un salut d'extrême droite menottes aux
poignets en rentrant en salle d'audience
est ce le geste d'un fou ou d'un
provocateur depuis le drame et cette
première audience en février dernier le
tueur norvégien a intrigué les
psychiatres
l'homme qui avait posé des bombes à oslo
a battu méthodiquement des adolescents
en congrès sur l'île d'utoya et fait 77
morts avait d'abord été déclaré
irresponsable en novembre dernier au
grand dam de l'opinion d'un pays
traumatisé
un second collège d'experts vient de
rendre un avis totalement différent nous
avons conclu que le prévenu n'était pas
atteint de troubles psychiques au moment
des faits nous n'irons pas plus loin car
le reste du rapport et secret pénalement
responsable une conclusion des
psychiatres qui en tout cas ravi le
détenu breivik qui se définit comme un
militant contre l'islamisation et a
appris cette nouvelle avec satisfaction
selon son avocat il est d'accord avec
les psychiatres sur le fait qu'il est
complètement sain d'esprit
il veut profondément s'expliquer sur ses
attaquants font mais je tiens à préciser
que ce sera vraiment dur d'entendre ses
justifications
il ne fera pas que s'expliquer il dira
aussi qu'il ne regrette qu'une chose ne
pas avoir tué plus de personnes des
félins quoi qu'il arrive le procès
d'anders breivik filmé ici lors d'une
reconstitution s'ouvrira lundi prochain
à oslo
mais c'est en juillet au moment de
prononcer la peine que le tribunal
tranchera définitivement sur sa
responsabilité pénale ou non qu'il aille
en prison ou en hôpital psychiatrique
il encourt l'enfermement à vie oui un
procès qui devrait donc durer deux mois
et demi l'arrogance et le narcissisme de
l'homme qui a terrifié la norvège c'est
une journée éprouvante qu'ont vécu les
survivants ou les familles des victimes
au premier jour du procès d'anders
breivik comme beaucoup le redoutaient il
a multiplié les provocations et laisse
échapper aussi quelques larmes sur place
stéphanie perez chloé cormery
un petit sourire puis une provocation un
salut d'extrême droite dès son entrée
dans la salle d'audience
le message dans le derche breivik est
clair il compte faire de ce procès une
tribune pour ses idées dans son costume
cravate il semble très calme et s'est
fermement qu'il commence par contester
l'autorité du tribunal
je ne reconnais pas la légitimité de ce
tribunal
son mandat est issu d'un parti politique
qui adhèrent au multiculturalisme
pendant une heure la procureure égrène
le nom des victimes
tout ou presque tué d'une balle dans la
tête silence pesant parmi les proches
des victimes présents dans la salle
breivik lui reste impassible comme un
différend avant une nouvelle provocation
je reconnais les faits mais je n'en
coupable car j'ai agi en légitime
défense
heart of la séance est suspendue nouvel
acte de défiance breivik refuse de se
lever comme c'est l'usagé
quand la cour quitte la salle breivik
fidèle à lui-même
froid et déterminé
jusqu'à la diffusion de son manifeste de
propagande contre le multiculturalisme
contre toute attente il fond en larmes
lui qui se moque du sort de ces victimes
craque quand il se retrouve au centre
des débats
ce qui laisse certains des rescapés
d'utoya dubitatif c'est la première fois
qu'une manifeste des émotions sans tabou
est ce parce qu'il est fier de lui ou
parce qu'il a l'impression qu'il a perdu
la bataille pour la justice norvégienne
ce procès est un défi même si l'accusé
est hors norme magistrats et aux
psychiatres lui ont serré la main comme
c'est la coutume pas de justice
d'exception
c'est une question de principe bonsoir
c'est fanny on vous retrouve en direct
sur place qu'elles sont finalement les
enseignements de cette journée
mais à côté je peux vous parler du
malaise qui a saisi la salle d'audience
aujourd'hui parce que les familles des
victimes et les journalistes et bien
nous sommes assis à deux trois mètres
seulement de landers brevik et on peut
le voir de temps en temps se retourne et
jeter un petit coup d'oeil dans la salle
pour vérifier qu'il est bien au centre
de l'attention
c'est assez troublant troublant aussi
cette indifférence permanente au sort
des victimes cet après midi la cour a
diffusé un appel téléphonique d'une
jeune fille coincée sur l'île d'utoya
elle appelle la police elle est paniquée
elle est terrifiée on la sent à bout de
souffle
on entend les dizaines de tirs derrière
elle la salle est saisi d'effroi
mais lui est resté impassible glacial
c'est confirmé
pendant ces dix semaines de procès pour
les familles ça va être une épreuve
vraiment vraiment bouleversante
merci stéphanie à vous l'avez dit
rappelons que ce procès sera long le
verdict sera rendu au mois de juillet
prochain dans l'actualité également la
condamnation dans le gers breivik
l'auteur de la tuerie d'utoya il a été
condamné à 21 ans de prison la peine
maximale prévue par la justice sur place
en norvège le soulagement est immense
bernard lebrun pascal stelletta
l'heure de la sentence a sonné mais rien
ne semble impressionner ou pouvoir
effacer le rictus permanent de cet
assassin de 33 ans qu'il était dernier
sur l'île d'utoya vole à la vie à 77
personnes dont nombre d'étudiants à coup
de fusil est le plus souvent à bout
portant
provocateur jusqu'au bout et manifestant
son engagement de militants d'extrême
droite anders behring breivik a
finalement été jugé sain d'esprit par
les experts psychiatriques et la
présidente de prononcer le verdict voici
les conclusions du jugement rendu à
l'unanimité
anders behring brevik né le 13 février
1979 est reconnu coupable d'avoir
enfreint les lois et condamné à 21 ans
de prison avec un minimum de dix ans
ferme et brevik d'afficher un large
sourire tant il est satisfait de ce
jugement qui le condamne à la prison
plutôt qu'à l'hôpital psychiatrique
ainsi pense-t-il pouvoir faire des
émules de sa cellule
ce verdict qui apparaîtrait
incroyablement clément ailleurs
satisfait pleinement en norvège y
compris les familles des victimes
je trouve que le jugement a été bon
c'est la peine maximale que l'on puisse
donner en norvège donc je suis
satisfaite
j'espère que breivik restera enfermé
entre catherine allure et jusqu'à sa
mort tm les raids spa choix car en
norvège
la justice peut rallonger la peine
prononcée par le tribunal tant que
l'individu est jugé dangereux dans
l'immédiat breivik sera détenu à
l'isolément total
bonsoir finistère on va retrouver en
direct d'oslo commence ce procès at il
été vécu sur place par les norvégiens
eh bien écoutez pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux ils ont trouvé et que le
procès était exemplaire les habitants
que nous avons rencontrés tout à l'heure
à oslo nous disait que breivik avait été
jugé avec dignité qu'ils avaient
bénéficié de tous les droits d'un accusé
normale et pourrait bien c'était là
l'essentiel qu'ils étaient très fiers de
leur système judiciaire
alors malgré tout une partie de
l'opinion publique estime que les juges
ont été un peu trop complaisant
vis-à-vis de lui notamment le lait sans
faire à maintes reprises son salut nazi
en lui donnant beaucoup la parole en lui
sans même la main en début d'audience
c'est trop et ça nous a choqués c'est ce
qu'on me disait tout à l'heure une jeune
femme est bien qui a perdu un ami sur
l'île d'utoya alors c'est un sentiment
donc qui est partagée malgré tout les
norvégiens estiment que le fait de faire
le salut nazi
et bien c'est à traiter avec mépris ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance tous en
revanche sont d'accord sur un point le
pays ne veut plus entendre parler de
breivik et espère que bien que les
médias arrêteront de parler lui puisque
c'est tout ce qu'il attend
[Musique]